allez pour le moment seolen Royal est
avec nous elle va nous faire tout
comprendre sur le 493 c'est seolen
[Applaudissements]
s'explique a ramené des cadeaux des
petit cadeau et oui elle n'est pas les
main VI je vais vous expliquer ce que
c'est que le 493 mais vous savez
peut-être déjà un petit peu ce ce que
c'est mais comme ça revient dans
l'actualité allez c'est important de de
le savoir est-ce que c'est des
kilomètres 49 est-ce que c'est des kilos
est-ce que est-ce un chrono 493 est-ce
que c'est un chrono et Cera fait 2
secondes de mieux
que donc 493 c'est un numéro c'est le
numéro d'un article de la Constitution
qu'est-ce que c'est que la Constitution
la Constitution c'est un peu disons le
mode d'emploi le règlement du
fonctionnement des pouvoirs public en
France comment fonctionne le président
de la République le Gouvernement le
Parlement les relations et ce et cetera
et dans cette Constitution il y a un
article 493 qui prévoit en effet que
dans certains cas on peut faire voter
c'est-àdire on peut faire adopter une
réforme sans la faire voter et sans la
discuter c'est ce qui est arrivé à la
réforme des retraites et donc je vais
vous expliquer ce qu'il y a dans ce
texte et comment se fait ce qu'on
appelle la hiérarchie des des valeurs
pour que vous puissiez juger si c'est
normal ou pas d'utiliser le 493 sur des
sujets qui concernent vraiment
profondément la vie des français et qui
a par exemple permis de baisser le
niveau de des retraites donc pour que
vous comprenez bien je vous ai apporté
des
constitutionsenez vous allez prendre la
page 22 s'il vous plaît voil P il y en a
une pour tout le monde donc vous suivez
ch voilà merci tenez tenez
voilà alors vous vous suivez vous suivez
à TR vous suivez à TR parce vous prenez
la page 22 prenez la page 2 partagé
alors ce qui est très important c'est de
dire ben voilà l'article 49 voyez il
vient assez loin dans les articles de la
Constitution et ce qui est important
c'est de reprenez le le premier article
je vous ai fait une petite coche parce
que le principe fondamental de de
fonctionnement de notre République c'est
ce qu'on appelle la souveraineté du
peuple donc y a deux phrases toutes
simples la France est une République et
son principe est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le peuple et
la souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qu'il exerce par ses
représentants ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les députés qui sont élus par
nous représente le peuple et donc sont
censés lorsqu'ils votent nous
représenter al on pense que c'est
compliqué la Constitution mais c'est
très simple d'ailleurs vous vous en
connaissez une bonne part regardez la
langue de la République française et le
français franis l'emblème national bravo
bravo bravo l'emblème national et le
drapeau ble blanc rouge blanc rougeore
l'hymne national est
la la devise de la République est
libertéitéé donc là vous voyez vous
connaissez l'article 2 de la
Constitution et il y a une petite phrase
qui est beaucoup moins connue que je
viens de vous donner c'est son principe
c'est le gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple et pour le peuple et c'est pour
ça que quand le 493 que vous avez là
page 22 dans la page qui prenez la page
22 qu'est-ce que ça veut dire 493 d'
vous avez fait toutes les pages comme ça
non non non non c'est juste pour le 4
non mais je sais vous avez fait pour le
monde tout le
monde
ou c'est
beau déjà regardez ce qu'on vient de
voir avec la souveraineté du peuple
c'estàdire que normalement tout le monde
doit fonctionner le président de la
République le Gouvernement le Parlement
dans dans l'intérêt du peuple pour
améliorer la situation du peuple pour
pour être faire preuve de bienveillance
à à l'égard du peuple pour que les
choses progressent et ensuite beaucoup
plus loin il y a le cet article 49 donc
voyez il est beaucoup moins important
que le principe de la souveraineté
populaire on est bien d'accord et
pourquoi
493 c'est parce que c'est le 3è
paragraphe donc je vous ai mis le 3è
paragraphe donc vous voyez que cet
article qui aujourd'hui est très sans
débat sans vote il est très loin il a
une petite place dans la Constitution
donc l'idée c'est qu'il ne doit pas être
utilisé comme un
instrument
habituel de gouvernance c'est pas
l'esprit de lation il y a rien qui
l'indit c'est
c'est voyez il a pas être utilisé en
permanence il a été utilisé la 12 fois
il a et surtout sur des sujets aussi
importants qui ont besoin d'être
débatttu et pourquoi il est donc vous
voyez c'est C aligné à 3 c'estd un
projet considéré comme adopté sauf si
une motion de censure est déposée dans
les 24 heures bah voilà
pourquoi est-ce que aujourd'hui ou un
pouvoir qui est minoritaire utilise ça
parce qu'il a une loi ou une réforme a
besoin d'une majorité qu'est-ce que
c'est que la majorité aujourd'hui
combien il y a de députés il y a 577
députés donc la majorité est à
289 députés et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement n'a que 245 députés donc
pour faire une réforme il est obligé de
discuter mais c'est ce que c'est bien ce
que les Français ont voulu parce que si
les Français n'ont pas envoyé une
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée c'est
parce qu'ils ont voulu justement que sur
les sujet important et bien des gens qui
n'ont pas la même opinion politique
puissent discuter pour que les choses
soient plus intelligemment faites par
rapport à la prise en compte de la
complexité des choses de la réalité du
terrain de la diversité des expériences
et cetera et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui le 493 est encore moins
justifié et moins justifiable parce que
justement il y a pas la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc c'est
comme quand ça qu'on fait plushabitude
voilà et donc quand ce principe est trop
brutalement appliqué et bien ça ça met
en échec ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
c'est plus le pouvoir du peuple par le
peuple et pour le peuple et quand le
peuple passe derrière un ce dont ils ont
envie c'est ce qui leur fait du bien et
ce qu' leur donne des règles et des
repères là vous êtes dans dans le
respect mutuel est dans la juste
exercice de juste exercice de l'autorité
voilà ça doit rester exceptionnel donc
ça doit rester exceptionnel est-ce que
vous avez des questions s plaîtelfin
vespizer est-ce que le référendum ce
serait pas une bonne solution pour
contrer l'article 493 alors précisément
oui c'est une bonne question parce que
le référendum c'est d'ailleurs dans la
Constitution c'est la souveraineté
populaire c'est soit par ses
représentants soit par le référendum
mais si l'on suit cette question à
propos de de la réforme des retraites on
voit que s'il y avait eu un rérendom sur
les retraites les gens auraient répondu
non bien sûr donc c'est encore plus
paradoxal d'utiliser le 493 pour forcer
une réforme que les gens ne veulent pas
les gens ne voulaient pas avoir baissé
leur retraite surtout en période
d'inflation et il y aurait eu un
référendum çaurait été une bonne
solution les gens auraient le référendum
aurait été négatif puisqu'on le voyait
dans les sondages et à ce moment-là
c'était une façon élégante pour le
gouvernement de reculin en disant bah
non vous n'en voulez pas on ne le fait
pas mais souvent vous avez quoi vous une
livre de tomate oui merci oui votre
démonstration est limpide mais quand
vous étiez ministre par exemple dans le
gouvernement de Manuel Vals il a utilisé
le 493 est-ce qu'à ce moment-là vous
vous disiez ti éé utilisé là com il
é est-ce que là vous vous disiez à ce
moment-là tiens c'est pas la bonne
solution puisque le peuple est un peu
j'ai dit à ce moment-là ah vous l'avez
dit ah ou parce que moi je pense si vous
voulez que euh le fait d'imposer euh une
décision cette décision est forcément
mauvaise si vous ne prenez pas le temps
de discuter de faire des compromis de
comprendre pourquoi une majorité d'élu à
l'Assemblée nationale est contre une
décision parce que les gens les députés
ils sont en contact du peuple des gens
qui les ont élus donc ils font remonter
un certain nombre d'informations donc si
on dit non il faut pas faire cette
réforme c'est mauvais ça va faire du mal
aux gens il y a les gilets jaunes déjà
la taxe carbone regardez comme ça a été
imposé le mal que ça a fait rendez
compte il y a 15 manifestations pour les
retraites plus la répression plus tout
ça enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est
douloureux quand même qui s passé malgré
malgré tous les problèmes que l'on a
déjà sort du covid on a eu 15
manifestations sur les retraites c'est
pas raisonnable non c'est pas
raisonnable donc il faut être
raisonnable je pense raisonnable une
question pertinente est-ce que le 493
existe à l'étranger ou est-ce que c'est
une exception française par je faisais
beaucoup critiqué pour l'avoir utilisé
notamment à l'étranger c'est une
exception française voilà ça c'est ça
c'est une bonne question c'est la
meilleure
question le pouvoir est beaucoup plus
parlementaire bons boir ou oui bonsoir
Valérie benim mais ça veut dire que vous
voudriez qu'on retire cet article 493 de
de la constioui apparemment oui je pense
qu'il faut pas l'utiliser sur des sujets
majeurs ah sur les sujets majeurs il
peut y avoir des des cas particuliers où
ça peut être peut-être encore pouroi
comme à la déidéo n'urait pas le droit
de retoucher son père c'estd vous
pourrait l'utiliser qu'une ou deux fois
par an par an une ou deux fois c'estàd
vous avz le droit d'utiliser trois fois
alors c'est cette réforme a déjà eu lieu
justement on a le droit de l'utiliser
qu'une seule fois par session parlementa
en 2008 ouais et pourquoi et là on l'
fait parce qu'il y a eu justement des
abus oui parce qu'il y a en plus sur les
lois de finances ça peut être fait en
plus les lois de finance la loi de
sécurité sociale c'est important c'est
notre santé c'est les c'est les
retraites c'est tout ça donc c'est des
sujets importants qui ne devrai pas être
adopté sans vote c'est très choquant
aujourd'hui d'adopter des choses sans
vote dans une démocratie dans une
république dont les articles premers de
la constititution disent que c'est le
pouvoir du peuple par le peuple pour le
peuple quand on retire le pouvoir au
peuple ou à ses représentant c'est une
forme de tyrannie et c'est pour ça
ensuite que les gens se se révoltent oui
et qu'est-ce que vous dites à ceux qui
disent que justement le 493 permet une
stabilité institutionnelle et c'est pour
ça que justement on l'a bonne question
tiens euh ben je réponds au contraire
c'est c'est un c'est un leur
c'est-à-dire que quand on quand on
impose des
choses quand on impose des choses malgré
la révolte populaire et malgré le
désaccord d'une majorité de députés
l'Assemblée nationale un jour ou l'autre
ça ressurgit mais quand on a pas de
majorité du coup on réforme pas parce
qu'on peut rien faire tout est bloqué
tout le temp on peut faire de bonnes
réformes ah oui on peut faire de bonnes
réformes qui sont qui sont consensuelles
vous voyez ça c'est mais Géraldine a
raison a utilisé ou 2 fois 28 fois
Michel Rocard fois c'est pour ça que ça
a été réformé ensuite Michel Rocard l'a
utilisé c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu la
réforme de 2008 qui a interdit de
l'utiliser une fois de plus mais c'est
pas parce que des choses mauvaises ont
été faites dans le passé qu' faut les
recommencer faut prendre les bons
exemples au contraire bien sûr bien sûr
dernière question dernière question qui
alors vous me le dites je je vais
choisir la
question vous me dites les trois
questions je en choisir une par 31 je
voulais savoir si si c'était ce qu'
avait le
plus une deè
chance pour éviter le 493 est-ce que
vous seriez favorable à une coalition
comme en Allemagne ou en Italie ça évite
complètement le 493 ça oblige le
gouvernement à faire copain copain avec
une autre formation politique il faut il
faut des coalitions par sujet sur un
sujet comme les retraites sur un sujet
comme les retraites on voyait bien que
c'était c'était pas bien cette réforme
en plus elle a beaucoup pénaliser les
femmes puisque allonger la durée de
cotisation ça pénalise très lourdement
les femmes qui ont qui ont des des
durées de carrière moins continu elles
se sont arrêté pour élever les enfants
et cetera et donc je pense que sur des
sujets de société oui il faut des des
des des majorités d'idées bien sûr c'est
ils peuvent garder la Constitution
cadeau alors c'est cadeau c'est c'est 1
€ c'est VO ah
ouais
[Applaudissements]
mercion